a warning this report from our southeast
asia correspondent siobhan robbins
contains images of violence and dead
bodies
[Music]
this is the story of a massacre in
myanmar
of at least 37 people brutally killed on
christmas eve
a majority christian community looking
forward to the holidays
now the site of one of the worst mass
killings since the military coup
[Music]
the military government says those who
died were suspected terrorists but
others claimed they were just ordinary
people
among the dead two charity workers a
disabled man
at least one child
so what happened on that day
[Music]
this is myanmar
[Applause]
a country torn apart by violence since
last february's coup
on one side the military or junta who
claiming electoral fraud overthrew the
government and took control
[Music]
on the other protesters armed groups and
militias fighting to restore democracy
[Music]
the christmas eve killings happened in
kyar state in eastern myanmar
it's an area which has seen some of the
most intense fighting between rebels and
military
[Music]
[Applause]
to piece together what happened our
teams in thailand myanmar and london
with investigators from myanmar witness
have analyzed images and tracked down
family members and witnesses
i have never seen anything like this
in my entire life
people tied up and killed
among those who died is a 28 year old
named lyra his siblings describe him as
a hard-working family guy
they also tell us his left hand isn't
fully formed it's an important detail
we'll come back to that later
at around 8 a.m on christmas eve lyra
leaves his home on his motorbike for the
final time
he's off to buy a car with a friend
at 10 a.m the junta says soldiers begin
stopping vehicles on this road
it's the one lira's thought to be
travelling on
four members of the junta allied border
guard force are sent to investigate
at 10 56
a man kukenya starts taking photos of
people fleeing a nearby village
they've heard gunfire
soon after local militia films and later
releases this it's the earliest footage
our team has found of the site analysis
of the shadows by experts at myanmar
witness suggest it was filmed around 11
30 a.m
a car belonging to two save the
children's staff is burning
three trucks carrying fuel are beginning
to smoke
but haven't yet burst into flames
suggesting the fire started fairly
recently
[Music]
shortly after they explode
by 119 the fires are big enough to be
picked up by nasa's fire detection
satellite
around 10 minutes later a rebel unit
reaches the site and films it
[Music]
the save the children car is now burnt
out
a few meters away the rebels tell us
they find four dead men
the bodies of the border guard sent
earlier to investigate why vehicles were
being stopped
hands tied they've been shot
and they aren't the only victims
[Music]
christmas day
rebels return and say they find 31
bodies burned beyond recognition
three bags of body parts are also later
collected
hello doctor
can you hear me okay
a doctor who did the post-mortem
examinations agreed to speak to us we
changed the names and voices of all of
the people we spoke to in myanmar for
their protection
the scars were completely smashed
maybe shot with a gun or beaten with
something and in the chest and back
there were some injuries from being
stabbed with a sharp object
there were bullet holes on the body and
most of the bodies were tied up
the level of violence is horrific the
damage to the bodies so extensive
it's hard to know everything that
happened
before they died
by now the military has broadcast the
level of violence is horrific
the damage to the bodies so extensive
it's hard to know everything that
happened
before they died
by now the military has broadcast its
version of events it says soldiers tried
to stop seven vehicles thought to be
linked to an alleged terror plot
it claims the people inside attacked
with bombs and guns
security forces shot back
then the vehicles caught fire
the military later says it tried to save
people
it claims the rebels killed the border
guards
it also issues photos of two dead men in
military-style uniforms calling them
enemies
but evidence we found
raises new questions
13 days after the massacre the militia
says it discovers two bodies in uniforms
matching the photo of the so-called
enemies near to the side of the fire
one is covered with branches
the other hidden by a rock
but these photos taken during the
post-mortem's show under the uniforms
the men are dressed in civilian clothes
both have been shot
but police tell us there are no bullet
holes or even blood on the men's
uniforms
and that's not all
in this image from state media the gun
looks unnatural as if it's been placed
on the body for a photo
and there's more by adjusting the
contrast on this photo
our team found the blur fades
this alleged soldier is missing his left
hand
it appears to be lyra who's not been
seen since the attack
we show his family they believe the
junta framed him and dressed him up to
make him look like a rebel fighter
they used heroes for it to state that he
was from the kmpp
they just wanted to clean up the
evidence
that's why they put the uniform on lyra
our team searched through the photos of
the burnt vehicles and found this
the motorbike police confirmed lira was
riding that day
his death was brutal
two teeth were missing his skull was
beaten and smashed
and there were two bullet holes in the
chest
and questions over the deaths of lyra
and his friend kulupe aren't the only
ones
the military says armed rebels died
while fleeing
so why were so many of the bodies tied
up
how can the deaths of two charity
workers and a young girl
be explained
we put this evidence to the military
government it hasn't responded
we also showed our findings to the un
human rights monitor for myanmar
the film uh that i've just seen is just
absolutely horrific
um and it's unfortunately not
uncharacteristic the myanmar military
are known for this again we need to
fully investigate it
but these have all the hallmarks of a
war crime
[Music]
the full scale of what happened here is
still unfolding
police say 40 people have been reported
missing those responsible for myanmar's
christmas eve massacre may never be
brought to justice
siobhan robbins sky news